well i think there's a number of things
we need to
tease apart when we think about net
neutrality um
there's the fundamental arguments about
what that means
in in in technical sense and we could
look at that
and then there's the the context in
which people legislate for net
neutrality which is done on a
per country basis and the way in which
it fits into each country's legislation
which leads to some of the slightly
weird arguments that you hear
so i think we start with the technicals
that's where i'm safest i mean
the idea of net neutrality is that you
shouldn't discriminate on the basis of
you know where i p packets come from so
what server you're talking to or who the
client is
and you shouldn't discriminate on the
basis of the protocol being used
um now we've seen this a number of times
we've seen
certain sites getting slowed down
because well we don't like what they're
doing and this is the argument that
net brutality advocates would have which
is that it can't be at the whim of a
commercial provider a service provider
decide to favor some websites over
another
and it's particularly the case there's a
concern
that for example isps
might be able to favor some
websites over others by asking people to
pay for preferential access so
you know large company a pays you know
the internet service provider to make
sure that their website's fastest
and that's considered a disadvantage
when it comes to innovation because
obviously small new interesting startups
wouldn't have the budget to be able to
go in and pay those extra premium
and in fact you know there's good
arguments here about
how much innovation has happened on the
internet we have seen lots of small
companies
grow into really big companies on the
internet in a short time
and we do have to remember that amazon
and ebay used to be minnows
compared to what was out there but
things like um
whatsapp and instagram you know if if
the likes of facebook
or even before that if myspace had been
able to buy bandwidth
and hence discriminate against facebook
then facebook wouldn't have risen so
you know this these are i mean these are
arguments that can be had about the
importance of the openness for
innovation
um so that's about discriminating based
on the service or the ip address
there's also discrimination by protocol
and this was quite popular for a number
of years
because certain protocols came to the
attention of the serbs providers because
they were consuming lots of bandwidth so
particularly file sharing
now whether the isps took a moral stance
on this and said that file sharing is
wrong because it can only ever be used
for
a breach of copyright um or whether they
simply took the view that well
we don't have enough bandwidth to go
around and these are heavy users
and they're making you know they're
ruining it for everyone else
um it doesn't really matter but they
started discriminating against that and
a bit torrent was the classic where lots
of people were discriminated against
bittorrent
um but then of course it turns out that
many people were using bittorrent for
perfectly legitimate reasons yes there
were bittorrent
foul sharing and there still is plenty
of it around um
and uh but then world of warcraft uses
bittorrent
to update its very big patches um very
useful it is too because that means that
in the days when my two kids used to
play world of warcraft as well then
we only had to download one patch to the
house and then it replicated inside the
house so
there's probably good reasons
discriminating on protocol is a very
blunt instrument because you have no
idea what people are using it for
in reality so those are some of the
arguments about
why net neutrality there's always the
case that service providers have the
right
to engage in certain traffic management
even where there is strong net
neutrality law
in order to keep the network operating
so for example during a distributed
denial of service attack
uh one of the things that lots of the
isps do is they will shut down where the
attacks are coming from
and they will throttle them and it's
like you couldn't say that that's a bad
thing
and likewise as we already know
certainly in the uk
but elsewhere there are
varying degrees of blacklisting of
websites
some of it because the material is
clearly illegal
others for example certain countries
have lists of
sites reckoned to have adult content and
while not illegal
many countries have put in place
legislation that says that
um that that uh consumers need to opt in
to see that
um rather than opt-out so there is
filtering going on uh there are times
when isps need to do things
and so it really is about getting a sort
of a rational balanced view
on the on the technical side about
promoting innovation
um and not allowing incumbents to
basically just hold on to their business
because they're the ones with the
deep pockets and that's that i think
that many people view that as being
critical for the success of the internet
so that's sort of the technicals and
that's the what these
net neutrality don't discriminate based
on you know protocols or
sources um but then we get into you know
a lot of the arguments are going on at
the moment
and particularly with the fcc um is
really about
previously the way in which the it was
decided that they would
try to enforce net neutrality which was
to use a particular piece of uh
prior prior legislation that had been
used to regulate
phone companies for many years and this
leads to lots of arguments which
in a sense are to do with the details of
that legislation and not to do with
this really the issue of net neutral
neutrality buried in the legislation is
the requirement for universal service
provision and the ability to
essentially tax all the consumers a
small amount in order to make sure you
can deliver
service everywhere and that was very
important the universal service
provision for telephony
was a major thing um 80 years ago or
something
which was to make sure that everyone
could get a phone since it was
considered critical especially as we
started moving to you know emergency
services
available by phone and the ability to
make in our case in the uk 999 calls
um um uh at any time and indeed we see
that today you see on your mobile phone
you can always make emergency calls so
embedded in that legislation was you
know things were there for a perfectly
sensible reason
but it's now being used as sort of a bit
of a bogeyman to say well
in the future uh under the current u.s
legislation in the u.s government could
decide that
these isps must raise these enormous tax
levies
and that's being used as an argument as
to why we can't possibly have this
legislation on the books
because that's got nothing to do with
anyone else anywhere else in the world
there's a very specific argument within
the us
and so we need to tease apart those
issues that are to do with
the underlying philosophy of net
neutrality and it's you know
enabling innovation from the very
specifics of what happens in any given
country
so again we look at some other countries
i mean the eu has put in place
legislation on net neutrality although
there are some people are concerned just
like loopholes there because in portugal
at least one provider is
um is charging uh differentially for
different services
and that's viewed as perhaps not in the
spirit of
what the legislation was meant to
achieve but
on the other hand it is legal so
they can currently do it under eu law
and there's other you know other
countries have looked at this in
different ways india certainly
i was very concerned that some of the
proposals around
um sort of free internet access for
certain websites
sponsored by certain large companies
would essentially prevent any
indigenous service provision and you
know social media provision in
particular
uh coming forward so that's we've got to
look at each country in turn
try to understand what's really going on
then the question is of course that
could could the change in the position
in the u.s
radically affect anyone outside the us
i mean most of this really reflects
around
the the consumer internet service
provider i
will not transit you know that uh us
consumer networks in order to get the
services even if from the uk or
elsewhere in europe rentals in the world
we're going to some large server farm
somewhere the chances are we don't
don't necessarily traverse those
networks um
so for a lot of people you know it
wouldn't make any difference but then
actually we need to look more generally
at the way in which
large-scale services are deployed these
days
most of your streaming video comes from
a content delivery network where the
content's been replicated all around the
planet
and the fact that um you know in the uk
large amounts of our content will be
coming across
the very narrow pond to the republic of
ireland um
we'll be getting all of our content from
there if it's not already in the uk
then in fact what the u.s does and what
u.s carriers do in the us will have
absolutely zero effect on us whatsoever
the danger always is though as the us
even though
the governance structures and everything
else for the incident has changed over
the years the us is still seen as sort
of you know
a leader in this area and one of the
concerns that
many folks have is that if they start
going down this path how many other
people might
you know think it acceptable go down
that path although as i say given that
the eu in particular has put in place
legislation
um then i don't see us doing a u-turn on
that
um if by us i mean those of us currently
in europe
let's let's see where brexit takes us uh
with that legislation in the future
people pay for services they want they
usually pay more if they want a better
service right what what's different
about
this rollback of net neutrality in those
two
well yeah i mean the world is full of
you know first
class seats and planes and business
class and a premium economy and economy
and
people paying different prices for
different things and you know in the
in the internet world you would say that
uh yeah there are different tariff
structures available
primarily and not here i can only really
speak you know for the uk primarily
simply based around volume
so it's not about discriminating one
against the other uh one service against
the other but simply by volume so people
will buy
i think i have four gigabytes a month on
my phone at the moment
and uh i hope i up and down that
depending on my usage
um i have to have you know no limits at
home because i
simply cannot control the kind of
content that
you know uh knowing that i have two
grown
grown lads at home streaming videos all
the time and playing online games
uh uh we would we would blast through
any cap that anyone would want to put on
us so there is that
it's the differential pricing between
different services and it's viewed as
um just a very on internet thing to do
um
to differentiate between the services
and i think that's slightly different
from
having you know tiered prices um
which uh you know simply reflects the
amount of
resource that you're using in the
network and perhaps that's where this
really comes down to is that
you know a packet is a packet i mean
yes maybe many of the isps would like to
look at some of those packets and go
that content is of higher value and
someone's making money out of it why
aren't we getting a piece of the action
you know that's a
very natural commercial behavior but um
we don't charge differentially for you
know a kilogram parcel depending what
the contents are i mean maybe you pay
insurance but the actual carriage is the
same
so it's the same principle here it
shouldn't be that the content is the
thing which is either the service or the
protocol
should dictate that these things are
different because bits as bits as bits
it's like
it's just like how many of them they
want to move and i think if we stick
with that
then you know that that general
principle with the exceptions i
mentioned about you know defending the
network against attack and
other scenarios that are perfectly valid
for as i say an operator to manage their
network
but stick with that principle then you
know that seems a reasonably
sensible one and you know the basis on
which many view the internet haven't
been a great success
there's a difference between the physics
and the engineering engineering one of
those gates and actually changing all
the computer architecture to move
towards those type of fredkin gates
is going to take an awful lot of effort
and an awful lot of cost but in
principle if we could do that and if we
had a
perfect perfect fred can get then there
would be no energy cost to computing